bonjour à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue de quoi vendre choisi de parler
aujourd'hui est bien de ce g7 qui
commence demain au canada un g7 qui
s'annonce périlleux avec des relations
entre donald trump et ses collègues
européens qui se sont largement tendues
ces dernières semaines l'heure n'est
plus vraiment aux démonstrations
d'amitié comme nous le verrons
autre sujet celui de ses députés
complètement débordés nous débattrons de
leur temps de travail réel ou supposé
mais aussi des dérives ou pas au
parlement des amendements par centaines
des séances interminables
est ce vraiment un plus pour la
démocratie notre troisième thème c'est
celui qui agite le parti
les républicains en ce moment le slogan
pour que la france reste la france qui
doivent ponctuer la campagne menée ce
week-end par le parti de laurent
wauquiez ne plaît pas à tout le monde
en interne c'est un euphémisme enfin
chers internautes vous avez certainement
un avis sur le sujet et doit-on
légiférer sur les faits que news c'est
ce que fait l'assemblée nationale depuis
aujourd'hui ce texte et il me bienvenu
est ce une loi de circonstance voir une
loi liberticide
bonjour à tous les cadres bonjour carole
barjon merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
chef du service politique de l'ops
vous êtes aussi intéressé à l'école à
l'éducation nationale dans mais qui sont
les assassins de l'école c'est votre
livre paru chez robert laffont en 2016
et l'ops la couverture de l'homme je
crois et sur bertrand cantat at il le
droit de chanter la polémique sur ses
concerts mais vous avez aussi un sujet
sur les fesses news intitulée l'effet
que news débarque macron et coop c'est
bien ça oui absolument
bonjour avec son a failli un merci aussi
nous avoir rejoints vous présidez le ce
think tank sinopia vous êtes aussi co
fondateur de l'observatoire citoyen du
renouveau démocratique
si nokia vous avez publié un manifeste
pour notre droit à être bien gouvernés
qui s'intitule et reprenons pouvoir
c'était en 2004 absolument bonjour
olivier duhamel à un jour merci aussi
vous nous fait le plaisir de nous
retrouver presque tous les jeudis vous
êtes juristes politologues
vous présidez la fondation nationale des
sciences politiques et vous êtes un
spécialiste des relations entre médias
et politique
c'est l'objet de votre émission média
police tous les
jeudi matin sur europe 1 à 10 heures et
c'est toujours passionnant et alors vous
nous avez préparé un spécial dédicace
vous avez présidé le jury de sciences po
puis photographe primo on va le voir
j'espère à l'écran le prix sciences po
de la faute aux politiques
c'est ça qui vient d'être décerné qui va
l'être tout à l'heure juste en sortant
d'ici je venais alors on a déjà les
résultats dans les arômes agacer ses
partenaires elle risque oui mais le
figaro magazine ne sort que de besoin il
est le les résultats j'espère taylorien
regarde pas et alors vous allez me dis
juste que le premier prix est attribué à
une photo fait par coline renault
c'était lors de cet
interview de emmanuel macron avec le
journaliste de tf1 jean pierre pernaut
on voit une dame qui regarde une dame
retraitée qui regarde l'écran ou à part
emmanuel macron et puis les deux autres
et ben on va garder on va dire à nos
internautes de regarder le figaro
magazine demain ou de regarder le site
ça sera sans doute sur le site très vite
voilà j'ai écouté merci alexis aussi
braisé de nous avoir rejoints directeur
des rédactions du figaro
on va parler donc de ce g7 alors la
malbaie c'est le nom de la localité qui
l'accueille au québec
est-ce que ça restera le nom d'un clash
entre grandes puissances occidentales
les sujets en tout cas de fâcherie ne
manquent pas les barrières douanières
mise par les états unis les sanctions
contre l'iran
alors avant même le début du sommet de
demain on parle d'un clan des 6 contre
donald trump
mais pas sûr que se feront en titre up
soit 6 unis que cela on va en parler
d'abord je vous propose d'écouter
emmanuel macron il a donné une
conférence de presse tout à l'heure ça
s'est terminé il ya une heure avec le
premier ministre canadien justin trudeau
et on va le voir il est assez remonté
contre la tentative d'hégémonie
américaine l'hégémonie c'est la loi du
plus fort l'hégémonie c'est la fin de la
règle de droit
l'hégémonie c'est la fin des garanties
qu'on peut donner à nos concitoyens
qu'on les protège selon des valeurs que
nous avons défendues et fait passer dans
ses textes et donc peut-être que ça est
égal au président américain aujourd'hui
d'être isolé mais nous ça nous est aussi
égal d'être à 6 si besoin était parce
que c'est si cela représente des valeurs
représentent un marché économique qui a
cette force de l'histoire et qui surtout
représente une vraie force au niveau
international aujourd'hui
et quant à la chancelière allemande
angela merkel
hier elle répondait aux questions du
bundestag enfin au bundestag et elle
elle est aussi assez ferme avant ce g7
on écoute
nouvelle faute offre de climats chauds
de politique
alors est ce que finalement emmanuel
macron individuel n'a pas raison quand
il dit on ne peut pas faire la guerre
côte à côte un extrait qu'on a passé
mais ce qu'il a dit on peut pas faire la
guerre côte à côte avec les américains
en syrie en irak au sahel et se faire
une guerre commerciale
on peut pas sauf qu'on peut c'est ce qui
est en train de se passer
donc voilà on ne peut pas on ne devrait
pas il n'est pas normal deux tomes et on
ne peut pas c'est assez surprenant
peut-être que c'est au fil des années si
j'essaie de servent de moins en moins il
faut bien le dire on n'en sort pas grand
chose les communiqués de plus en plus
oiseaux alors il n'est pas exclu
paradoxalement que celui ci servent un
peu plus que les autres
s'il permet justement aux six de faire
vraiment front contre les etats-unis
jeudi un peu plus parce que de toute
façon
l'hégémonie américaine elle se perpétue
les sanctions américaines
d'abord les taxations américaine elles
seront appliquées les sanctions
américaines contre ceux qui
continueraient à faire des affaires avec
l'iran
elles seront appliquées les grandes
entreprises du coup vont quitter l'iran
et donc c'est quand même relativement
limité comme conséquence mais si au
moins sur la position de principe et sûr
dans le cas dont on parle des taxations
d'éventuelles mesures de ressources
torsion bien ciblés etc
on se met d'accord c'est déjà quelque
chose j'ai cette utile alexandre à la
fin il faut voir d'où on vient on avait
un g8 les russes donc c'est quand même
pas une très bonne chose parce que sur
le plan de leurs internationaux
la grande question c'est dommage de pas
parler les russes maintenant on parle
d'un g7 g6 +1 on sait qu'à ta tion un g2
qui fonctionne essentiellement parce que
quand globalement les grands accru nos
politiques sont entre la chine et les
états unis
c'est vrai qu'on peut sans allocation de
à quoi tout ça sert bon après on peut
regretter que l'europe soit pas venu
représenter parce que finalement comme
nous quelque part nous la france tout
seul on a un peu de mal à faire cavalier
cavalier seul donc c'est vrai que moi
j'attends avec beaucoup de curiosité ce
qui va sortir de ce sommet si on se
replace du point de vue de ce que fait
l'europe en termes de poids politique
par rapport aux états unis on peut
sourire quand on voit
l'exemple très précis des sanctions
compris le canada de monsieur trudeau je
crois 11 milliards de dollars de
sanctions en rétorsion contre les
américains nous on en est à 3 milliards
et on a simplement 20 fois plus
d'habitants donc cette année donc oui je
suis un peu un peu inquiet je pense
qu'effectivement ce type de sommets au
moins de moins d'intérêt que ce qu'ils
avaient et il faudrait retrouver
effectivement un cadre de voilà de
multilatéralisme efficace ce qui pour
l'instant plus du tout cas cela dit ça
fait le jeu de trump qui est capable de
défendre le fait qu'il ya des alliances
il ya des alliances militaires et puis
il ya le business et tout ça est
séquencée le petit seul contre tous
justement ça le rend jusque là et dire
ça peut absolument servir la posture
qu'il a depuis le début seul contre tous
s'appeler à une partie des américains
être son peuple donc c'est pas forcément
mauvais pour lui
simplement il peut y avoir un clash pas
je parle moi j'ai trouvé par angela
merkel
le discours de rangdet la marque n était
clairement d'habitude ce genre de
réunions à vocation d'aboutir à un
communiqué commun et là il peut y avoir
à débarder communiqué commun qu'elles
étaient beaucoup plus doucement que je
trouve que moi je la trouve la svs
pierrick ça va être difficile
le sujet sont était elle prend sa fiche
et lillers sujet moi je suis absolument
d'accord je pense un peu pas les plaies
loin non plus bon peut-être qu on
signera pas de communiquer avec donald
trump
peut-être que sur certains points on
signera communiqué à 7 et sur d'autres
points comme du racisme
je pense pas que ça fasse trembler
donald trump mixa révolutionne des états
unis d'amérique qui est pas de
communiquer bon c'est très bien il faut
le faire instance inutile ce g7 pour
faire sur ce point là tous les pays ont
râlé contre cette affaire de sanctions
commerciales très peu bougé d'un iota
on découvre aujourd'hui que des tentes à
une torsion d'hégémonie américaine mais
enfin quand macro gate est hélas combien
de temps c'était un trois semaines à moi
c'était déjà la même je fasse la même
chose n'a pas réussi à le faire bouger
tous les états ont passé de le faire
bouger karité c'est qu'on fait pas
bouger présente ses génisses il a pas
envie de bouger et par ailleurs
notamment s'agissant de l'allemagne moi
je crois pas que ça ait l'air est ce que
les allemands ils ont quand même besoin
de des américains il ya quand même déjà
la brouille avec les russes on a que
chasser les russes du g8 à cause de
l'ukraine merkel est vraiment en
bataille avec les russes je pense pas du
tout qu'elle veut en plus se couper
totalement de ski malgré tout le
protecteur américain
donc ça que ça va faire un peu de mousse
et y est ça changera rien à la fin cette
lune de miel entre guillemets entre
emmanuel macron et donald trump à
laquelle on avait assisté
ça risque de nuire maintenant ou présent
français le côté justement à ces images
un peu même si l on était peut-être
exagéré dans les commentaires pas plus
que par moi je dirais que ce qui lui a
plutôt nuit c'était après son voyage aux
états unis où il y avait forcé fusion
avec le président américain
une semaine après il dénonce l'accord
avec la preuve le président américain
dénonce l'accord avec non c'est là où on
s'est dit que probablement emmanuel
macron s'était fait un peu avoir ou
avait été un peu naïf même s'il fallait
probablement qu'ils fassent les gestes
nécessaires mais moi je pense que c'est
les interrogations avec lui à ce
moment-là pas totalement naïf emmanuel
macron je pense qu'il fallait tenter
je crois que pour le coup pas c'est le
rôle de la diplomatie et des retraits
sont soit on fait la guerre soit on fait
de la diplomatie dont la chaise vide et
on fait rien n'a pas de sens sauf quand
on veut vraiment faire pression comme a
pu le faire de golden certaine époque
dans le cadre de certaines négociations
européennes
là en l'occurrence il fallait tenter à
son trait est une énigme
donc on sait pas on sait d'où il vient
mais on ne connaît pas bien on oublie
toujours que c'est un très très bon
négociateur en tout cas qu'il est il a
cette réputation là et donc il fallait
tenter depuis le départ de nouer une
alliance en essayant peut-être faire en
sorte que cette alliance est relations
pourraient un moment donné passer des
messages ont visiblement il est sûr de
son fait façon il est le plus fort de la
bande c'est clair sur un plan militaire
ces 700 milliards de dollars
sur le plan économique c'est le pays le
plus puissant du monde voilà ils ont la
loi américaine qui est extra territorial
qui m'ont fait très gros dégâts ils ont
leur du dollar à un moment de deuil
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont besoin de se mettre
à genoux devant les autres à la miss le
seul qui pourrait avoir un intérêt à pas
y aller aujourd'hui pour envoyer un
message c'est rome qui pourrait coûter
moi votre gsm g6v machin j'ai pas besoin
de galles et donc votre compromis si me
convient pas je le simba et ça change
rien à ma vie quoi alors ça c'est
maintenant est ce que disait m'a
contrainte qui revenait des etats-unis
il disait au voltage mais l'idée est
abandonnée à court terme tout ça ça peut
marcher à moyen long terme c'est dément
voilà et c'est ça oui effectivement à
moyen long terme c'est ça qui est un peu
inquiétant par rapport à la prospective
qu'on peut faire dire ça comme ça mais
le monde dans une état d'ébullition
certaines pas d'incertitude en tout cas
certaine bruno le maire faisait une
tribune je crois que c'était avant-hier
dans le hier dans le dans le figaro il
disait comment expliquer que les alliés
les plus proches des etats unis soient
traités comme la chine là aussi non
l'argument est valable c'est à dire que
pourquoi est-ce-que
les etats-unis n'ont tenu aucun compte
du fait que l'europe était leurs alliés
naturels pour prendre des sanctions qui
en l'espèce sur je parle des taxations
va sur l'acier l'aluminium représentent
des choses qui ne sont pas des enjeux
décisifs donc la critique elle vaut quoi
elle vaut il prend plus de vent avec la
chine qu'avec l'europe parce que le
rapport de forces est plus puissant du
côté de la chine mais ne tient aucun
compte du fait que l'europe est l'allié
traditionnel des etats-unis avait déjà
un petit peu engagé sa médecine à parce
que la chine vient de proposer 70
milliards d'importations supplémentaire
aux américains pour qu'ils ne n'applique
pas les sanctions donc lui peut dire à
ses électeurs vous voyez quand je menace
quand je fais des tarifs etc
les chinois ont déjà acheté 20 il
propose ses c'est vraiment le gars qui
est dans la négociation donc il tape
très fort puis voit ce qui se passe la
vie mais nous on n'a pas les mêmes armes
en face seul à vinitaly on avait fait un
moment là le dit qu'il était question
qui vieillit pas niva corey banks et un
petit zeste de g7 qui reste encore
quelques réactions d'internautes gens
sur lefigaro.fr trump est le roi de la
négociation on y revient il connaît son
affaire
trudeau merkel macro et les autres ne
font pas le poids devant lui amir
toujours sur lefigaro.fr il est très
dangereux de laisser les américains
dicter nos politiques étrangères et avec
qui on peut faire des affaires ou pas et
thomas qui s'interrogent quelle est
l'utilité du g7 par rapport au g20 quel
est l'intérêt réel de ce g7 dont s'est
posé la question je sais pas si vous
voulez répondre un peu plus sur ce point
en tout cas sur la question twitter
qu'on vous pose est composée sur twitter
eh bien vous êtes 71% a estimé que oui
ça prend le visage d'un g 6 contre trump
un dernier commentaire sur cette verra
comment est-ce qu'un type qui est un
carrefour à demi voire plus pitre va
peut-être absolument réussir c'est à
dire que les qualités en politique ne
sont pas celles que l'on loue d'habitude
dans les autres univers et jusqu'à
présent et
n'est pas exclu qu'il soit en train de
réussir un tournant historique avec la
corée du nord
il n'est pas exclu qu'il ait une
réussite économique à l'intérieur il
n'est pas exclu que compte tenu de tout
ça il se fasse réélire facilement c'est
trop tôt pour le dire mais c'est
possible
il y en moins c'est un cinglé qui twitte
qu'une à droite ce gr c'est lui même qui
continue à nous prouver qu'il est un
carrefour et trois quarts pitre mais il
va peut-être néanmoins réussi à trouver
d'accord moi je nuancerais alors ça vous
fait moins rire oui ça me fait mourir
des gens comme moi en tout cas je pense
qu'une bonne manière de présenter les
victoires aussi qu'il faut prendre avec
beaucoup de prudence présent sur le cas
de la corée du nord
je sais pas si c'est une victoire de
trump ou une victoire de kim moi je
serai pas loin de penser que c'est
finalement une victoire du nord coréens
parce qu'au bout du compte il est
réhabilité sur un plan international il
abandonne sa bon mais globalement il
s'en fiche et l'objectif initial de
trump qui consistait à renverser le
régime de corruption
tout le monde savait que le pouvoir
effectivement personne n'avait de 12 sur
l'incapacité de la corée a bombardé de
menin nuit avec une arme nucléaire
c'était c'était un moyen de négociation
moi je suis content que ça les inquiète
c'est sûr et c'est évident ça leur place
centrale mais normalement là on arrive
bien métrage sur l'autocratie d'abord
c'est pas si facile que ça et d'autres
encore au tour ce serait compliqué à
gérer
je pense que c'était plus un moyen de
négocier comme c'est dans d'autres cas
dans deux pays effectivement un vrai
moyen de pression et que et que ce moyen
de pression lui a permis effectivement
le mettant sur la table et au final en y
renonçant sous la pression de pékin
parce que vous deviez pas qu'à chaque
fois que vous l'avez un pas de côté ils
étaient allées à pékin juste avant et à
partir de là effectivement il a obtenu
ses aspects de réhabilitation et je suis
pas sûr sur une grande victoire pour
homme qui rêvait de faire tomber le
régime
s'il se met à lyon c'est parce que il ya
quinze jours autour du plateau on avait
commenté le fait qu'il ait donné d'être
jetés entre les deux corées ça sera
peut-être une paie de dupes et qu'à la
fin mais ça fera comme une victoire
diplomatique pour trump séquencé rien je
pense que c'est plus une victoire de
corée ou sinon sinon chinoise et mon
autre chose
on en reparlera un autre sujet tout à
fait différent effectivement celui de
ses députés qui seraient au bord de la
crise de nerfs avec obligés de
travailler presque deux week-ends
d'affilée les textes de lois
s'enchaînent à un rythme soutenu c'est
vrai et ces députés ils râlent contre la
mauvaise organisation du gouvernement
auront-ils raison ont-ils tort et est-ce
mieux avant je vous propose à voir
d'écouter le communiste andré chassaigne
qui n'est pas vraiment un nouveau venu à
l'assemblée
il parle de ce rythme infernal et qui
porte selon lui finalement atteinte aux
droits du parlement
on les écoute il était l'invité hier du
toc trois textes de lois très important
mais qu'elles il ya le texte de loi qui
vient d'être de passer sur l'agriculture
il ya le texte de loi en cours de
discussion sur le logement la loi et lin
et il ya la semaine prochaine le texte
la formation professionnelle c'est des
textes extrêmement bien sûr et on nous
impose un rythme pour aller vite il faut
réformer la france qui a réformé mais
certains disent depuis maintenant je
n'aime pas mais qui porte un coup à
notre possibilité par exemple
d'intervenir en séance avec un temps
programmé de défendre nos amendements
c'est plus une question de l'expression
des députés de deux droits
parlementaires qu'une question de volume
de travail
alexis on a publié cette page hier sur
ce temps de travail il a raison andré
chassaigne finalement c'est alors
statistiquement après on peut discuter
d'un sont deux choses où tout est
absolument remarquable qu on va 2,2 des
comptes statistique n'entraînera
attendait là c'est franchement c'est
assez bluffant de décompte statistiques
des heures de travail voilà c'est là des
députés il ya deux mesures et la mesure
en nombre de séances parce que là ça
c'est le tableau des eriad avoir la
mesure en nombre de séances on se rend
compte qu'en nombre de séances il ya 4 %
de plus que la période 2012-2013 que
donc que sous 4,60 plus que ce soit
hollande sait pas mais en nombre
d'heures travaillées entre guillemets
c'est moins c'est à dire que finalement
sous mac rond il ya moins d'heures si
léger moins longtemps que l'on sait
moins que ce soit hollande 1967 sept
heures du 1er octobre au 31 mai sous mac
row et 1052 à une période équivalente
soit au land et 650 sous sarkozy 20% des
roses
[Rires]
et chose est sûre c'est que je pense que
les gens ça les fait hurler de rire
enfin bon concert que la députée trop en
faire oui les gens le meilleur et je
sais ce que que ce soit vrai il faut il
est d'ailleurs j'admire beaucoup la
précision du travail du figaro et maman
c'est dans ces moments là qu'on aime
lire ce journal je tiens à le dire mais
pour les français entendez députés se
plaint de trop travailler ou le
président de l'assemblée nationale que
les députés travaillent et rétro mais on
est par les temps qui courent en italie
et ailleurs député dans se plaindre de
trop travailler alors qu'elle telle
rupture entre les français basé leurs
représentants mais c'est ne rien
comprendre au monde dans lequel on vit
au moment dans lequel il se trouve
pour jeannie totalement
l'éditorial de guillaume tabard qui ce
matin dans le figaro disait c'est une
affaire à régler entre les personnes
concernées on voit l'état les en place
publique ne pourra que remonter un peu
plus l'opinion contre les élus alors
cela étant il ya aussi un côté
organisation les députés disent oui mais
c'est mal fichu le vendredi c'est
désagréable non mais c'est pas le bout
du monde non plus est-ce que c'est pas
un peu la faute du gouvernement et sa
volonté finalement de traiter les
parlementaires comme quantité
négligeable
le gros du travail se fait quand même en
commission c'est à dire que ce qu'il
faudrait regarder et éventuellement
critique et sait comment ça s'est passé
en commission dans le c'est là où on
examine dans le plus grand détail les
textes et je signale que maintenant à la
différence de ce qui se passait avant
2008 quand ça vient à l'assemblée on
vote pas sur le projet du gouvernement
vote sur le texte tel qu'il sorte de la
commission donc c'est vraiment là le
travail fondamental
après c'est frustrant pour l'opposition
de ne pas avoir assez de temps pour
développer ces critiques mais c'est pas
la phase décisive du travail
parlementaire
carole connaissez brun le fond pour
aller dans le sens de ce que disait liés
je crois me souvenir qu'il ya eu un
débat à l'automne sur le fait que les
députés pouvaient faire prendre en
charge les frais de garde de leurs
enfants par des nounous
donc si vous voulez tout ça et ça c'est
des choses comme ça qui avait été
beaucoup relayé évidemment sont des
choses très concrètes
donc quand vous mettez ce genre de
privilèges ou davantage en tout cas par
rapport à ces protestations
oui c'est un calage est un peu il et
quel âge un peu un peu rude
alors je sais pour ce décalage nos
internautes aussi le souligner nous
avons
lohan qui nous dit c'est indécent je
suis patron de pme de huit personnes je
travaille 70 heures par semaine pour
2200 euros et jérémy sur facebook et
bientôt nous allons les voir faire grève
est le résultat de la question car au
final votation sur le figaro.fr c'est
pourquoi on a fait 2 938 non mais je
veux dire alors de temps en temps on
était quatre mois il va faire un 100 %
notre notre challenge
non que ça sorte maintenant ça explose
de polémique sur le fait qu'on travaille
trop alors qu'en plus il ya eu cette
information comme quoi les les
collaborateurs des parlementaires les
administrateurs experts a été très très
bien payé et qu'il y avait une opacité
oui mais sauf que s'agrègent bien y
regarder c'est vrai que messager
difficilement audible alors qu'après on
puisse se plaindre en tant que citoyen
que la fabrication de la loi mériterait
d'être un peu plus un peu améliorée que
les textes soient travail est d'ailleurs
un peu plus d'efficacité elle a par
exemple typiquement maintenant via
détournés si j'ai bien compris comme le
cas le gouvernement a saturé l'agenda
maintenant c'est les parlementaires qui
entre la main nue ministres vont
présenter la fameuse version des faits
que nous
bon c'est intéressant de voir qu'on
essaie de s'arranger comme on peut pour
arriver à faire avancer les choses avec
des textes sur une qualité relative puis
moi je m'inquiète un autre point c'est
que le parlement des jours pas mention
dans son rôle sur le contrôle du
gouvernement
de ce point de vue là il fait pas le job
est-ce que carole sur l'autre côté
amendement justement pas les députés la
france la république en marche des
pauses quantité d'amendements pour
exister pour s'émanciper un peu
justement du côté godillots où il
réalise pas que les députés de la
république en marche je veux dire touche
tous les députés un des tournants les
parties ont toujours fait ça c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que le gouvernement
veut effectivement limiter la
possibilité enfin deux le nombre
d'amendements
bon effectivement eux-mêmes voilà
utilisent ce genre de dérive donc mais
mais la vérité c'est vrai qu'il ya
peut-être trop d'amendements puisqu'on
sait très bien que il y en a qui sont
exigés exactement de la même manière il
ya seulement l'adjectif qui changent
enfin bon donc il ya il ya des abus de
tous les côtés mais c'est vrai que les
députés la république en marche le fond
et ils le font comme l'ont fait graver
maintenant vous avez de plus en plus de
posséder de dévaluation des
parlementaires et que dans l'évaluation
été rapportés le classement nos députés
voilà c'est un critère important les
gens se disent moi je veux pas prédit ce
que je fais rien et donc ils vont
déposer des amendements
ce qui prouve que c'est un peu un effet
pervers de l'évaluation des députés les
vins sont qualitatives elle est très
difficile élévation camp du non cumul
parce que quand on a fait nos communes
lundi mais non plus que ça à faire il
fonce à fond ils sont très contents
bon et maintenant ils ne font que ça et
d'ailleurs je pense qu'ils s'en fait
plus assidus notamment en commissions
que les députés d'abord parce que le
député d'avant quand ils n'ont pas envie
d'y aller j'allais pas il s'occupait de
leur commune faisait part hier ils ont
prouvé leur commune de leur département
etc et est donc y trouver leur équilibre
et autres fois où il était cumulards et
se plaignait pas de trop travailler là
ils n'ont plus que ça à faire il
travaille mais c'est peut-être aussi
c'est peut-être finalement une des
fragilités de cette affaire d'une
occurrence que c'est aussi la nouvelle
génération députés qui viennent plus
j'ai la société civile qui sont moins
peut-être qu'il découvre que fier
qu'elle mérite et qu'ils allaient se la
couler douce
ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il ya eu
pendant plusieurs semaines ya pas eu
grand chose à faire mais ça c'est des
questions de politique c'est compliqué
de gérer les projets doit et puis là
pendant la plainte projet doit son
arrivée donc ils ont eu trois semaines
on leur a demandé de travailler devenir
revenir à l'assemblée
bon c'est pas grave mais c'est pas non
plus encore quelques réactions amir qui
nous dit n'ont pas le droit de se
plaindre ils sont très bien rémunérés
pour leur travail et béatrice et pendant
ce temps là il y a les internes en
médecine qui n'arrête pas la comparaison
vaut ce qu'elle vaut mais bon l on va
passer à notre troisième thème alors
c'est le tract qui doit être distribué
dans toute la france ce week-end par les
militants les républicains il fait grâce
et beaucoup de dents c'est surtout son
slogan pour que la france reste la
france qui irritent au sein des
républicains alors s est un prétexte de
plus pour la fronde anti vos pieds on va
en parler mais d'abord on va regarder
virginie calmels vice-présidente des
républicains elle n'en pense pas que du
bien elle est l invité de france inter
ce matin tracts effectivement il est à
mon avis un peu déséquilibré en ce sens
qui il ne parle que des sujets régaliens
et pas assez de mon point de vue
d'économies et je pense que nous devons
aussi parce que nous sommes aujourd'hui
le premier parti d'opposition encore
debout que nous sommes un parti de
gouvernement et que justement si je me
bats aujourd'hui dans cette famille de
la droite à ses habits mais c'est pour
éviter la montée des populismes et pour
éviter que nous connaissions un jour en
france que l'italie vient de connaître
olivier duhamel d'abord sur le slogan
finalement il est efficace il est de
votre point de vue il a au moins
l'efficacité du fait qu'on parle que de
ça donc ça s'est jamais on n'a autant
parlé depuis très longtemps d'impact des
républicains aida je sais pas pour tout
vous dire j'ai du mal à vraiment vous
faire une réponse dont soient convaincus
et vous avez le net leur camp mais oui
mais je vais vous dire pourquoi parce
que je ne sais pas quelles étaient les
intentions des auteurs de ce tract enfin
très exactement de cette mise en valeur
de la formule pour que la france reste
la france soit il avait une intention
délibérée de prendre un slogan qui
t'avait un aspect néo lepéniste proches
du front national en disant ça va nous
en faire prendre un peu de plus c'est là
où est le problème pour nous c'est là où
il faut qu'on gagne des voix
tant pis si on passe pour crypto front
national c'est pas grave c'est ce qu'il
faut faire
première hypothèse deuxième hypothèse il
dit cette formule d'ailleurs dont on
peut aussi avoir une interprétation
relativement creuse comme elle a été
prononcé par françois hollande comme
elle a été prononcée par nicolas sarkozy
comme elle a été prononcée par emmanuel
macron comme elle a été prononcée par
les dirigeants socialistes
on pourrait vous trouvé dans les
archives
20 truc de gens qui ont dit formique
partie soucier du parti socialiste a
déçu parce que ce serait ce la france
avec les services publics à la française
voilà or je ne sais pas quelle est entre
c'est peut-être qu'ici il ya des gens
qui le savent autour de cette table
moi j'ai le but est de vous dire je ne
sais pas quelle est la réalité de leur
intention et donc je reste perplexe
la question est ouverte car albert jours
vous avez une réponse non mais c'est
vrai que c'est assez assez difficile bon
on imagine tout de même que l'intention
voilà de laurent wauquiez c'est
probablement aussi de rappeler des
slogans similaires qui était la france
aux français par exemple ou des choses
comme ça que j'ai utilisé le front
national puisque on sait que l'un des
ses objectifs c'est de récupérer quand
même des électeurs de marine le pen donc
voilà une job mais c'est vrai qu'au lit
jamais là a raison de dire que c'est
suffisamment comment dire ambiguë voilà
pour que puisse m'a finalement alors
pourquoi s à des républicains a créé de
tels remous et c'est sans doute
effectivement s'il ya quelques
arrière-pensées s'alarme était d'abord
sur le fait moi j'ai pas d'information
mais je pense comme l'intuition que
wauquiez c'est à peu près ce qui fait
donc il choisit une transgression il
monte le son de la transgression
précisément parce que ce sera terrible
de la transition pour l'instant ne
produit pas ou peu d'effet donc il faut
il faut monter le son
et je pense qu'il se dit et à juste
titre que sur un slogan comme ça si on
fait demain un sondage pour dire est ce
que vous êtes d'accord pour que la
france reste la france
80 % des gens disent oui donc un terme
13-13 font ça on va voir servent à le
faire donc il est il en terme d'opinion
il est gagnant le problème c'est qu'il a
un front de l'opinion et à franc de son
parti et que vu le climat dans son parti
où il avait beaucoup de gens contre lui
qui disait ça marche pas et c qui
critiquent sa stratégie dite de
droitisation il ya de ceux qui en
profitent
calmels ne t'a pas tellement fort info
est elle dit juste il devrait passer
prime devrait parler plus d'économies au
passage il en parle parce qu'il n'y a
jamais eu autant d'impôts y ait jamais
eu autant d'immigrés donc il parle aussi
d'économie mais les critiques de calmels
elle lui reproche pas ce qu'il dit dont
elle lui reproche qui dit pas mais enfin
si on regarde le climat aujourd'hui à
l'intérieur des républicains où il est
sous forte pression critique
c'est évident que mais au fond je pense
qu'il a renoncé alors peut-être qu'il a
tort ça sent une autre affaire mais à
réunir autour de fédérer les les
chapelles et les souches appel soit ils
s'en fichent soit il a compris que ça
marcherait plus et maintenant il n'a
plus qu'un truc à faire c'est l'opinion
comme sarkozy l'avait fait une époque
avec le ministère de l'identité
nationale et tout ça et ça avait quand
même marché la difficulté aujourd'hui ça
n'a pas marché mais peut se dire que
demain ça marchera voilà on le sent on
le verra mais il va falloir aller assez
vite parce que les européens n'arrivent
parmi les critiques avaient celle je
crois que c'est dans un chez nos
confrères du parisien de bruno
retailleau qui disait il faut se méfier
des slogans le pire pour nous serait de
remplacer la pensée par des trappes
franchement dans un tract qu'on
distribue sur les marchés on met quoi si
on met pas des slogans
c'est le principe d'un track c'est de
mettre des slogans c'est pareil il faut
connecter la forme au fond quoi s'est il
faut que le fond remonte et c'est un peu
le point de l'ambiguïté qui au travers
de cette formule c'est que derrière il
faut il faut communiquer ça une pensée
aux qu'on peut assumer et à mon avis
c'est ça qu'il faut faire c'est assumé
et si on voit qu a priori comme ça un
peu de divergences entre les uns et les
autres c'est dommage parce que justement
c'est peut-être l'occasion sur un sujet
qui est un vrai sujet était finalement
on veut un doux on est où on veut aller
où parce que c'est un poème de
trajectoire dessus il faut faire un
derrière mon avis un débat il faut avoir
une position politique peut-être plus
clair que ce qu'on entend jusque là
parce qu'après on peut être d'accord ou
pas mais en tout cas le message est
quand même relativement signifiant
derrière on comprend bien qu'il ya
quelque chose qui est en train de nous
échapper qui glisse et que c'est
peut-être sur cette quelque chose qui
nous échappe et qu'ils disent qu'il faut
travailler pour éviter qu effectivement
la france ne change trop mais elle
change commencer aussi ça qu'il faudrait
un peu clarifiée
mais sinon ça révèle rien comme un
problème de fonctionnement au sein des
réplicateurs qui est curé louis
alexandre à la faille vous me fournisse
une transition parce que lydia guirous
sport par porte-parole des républiques
ajustements justifier à 6 c'était mardi
sur la chaîne parlementaire
ce slogan elle parler du fond moi la
france c'est la france des lumières
c'est celle de voltaire c'est celle de
simone veil oui j'aime cette france et
je veux que cette france des libertés
reste la france je ne veux pas que nous
cédions à la montée de l'obscurantisme
qui existe dans certains quartiers et
que certains coire ne veulent absolument
pas voir parce qu'ils sont installés
dans leur dans leur confort et qui
s'estime ne pas être touché par par
cette montée du communautarisme il ya
absolument rien de choquant dans ce
slogan au contraire c'est beau c'est un
message d'espoir une bonne argumentation
carroll en tout cas je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de penser que ce slogan est
ce qu'elle vient de dire est aussi
peut-être une réponse aux propos d'
emmanuel macron récent lorsque
jean louis borloo présentait son rapport
et qu'il a parlé de mâles blancs ce qui
est un vocabulaire quand même qui
beaucoup celui de gens qui sont assez
communautariste d'ailleurs des indigènes
de la république des gens comme ça qui
parle de racisées voilà et et on se dit
que dans ce contexte là ce slogan répond
à cette préoccupation que la france
reste la france
enfin cette souci de la permanence est
au coeur de des prometic françaises
européennes et finalement occidentales
parce que le break site c'est que le
l'angleterre reste l'angleterre est ce
que le vote en italie c'est que la
hongrie d'italie reste l'italie et le
vote en allemagne la montée l'éviter
c'est que c'est que l'allemagne reste
l'allemagne dont qui met le doigt sur
quelque chose d'absolument juste aidé
abstrait qui qui parle vraiment
l'opinion
après la question c'est quelles sont les
réponses qui va apporter à sa sur
l'immigration sur l'islam sur plein de
choses
ils prennent ici que tout le monde ne
mettra pas le non sens dans la franc
renvoyé mais l angoisse apparait dire
qu'à des gens qui diront pour que la
france reste la france
il faut qu'elle reste accueillant un
pays des droits de l'homme qui
accueillit des italiens des espagnols
des portugais des polonais et qui
maintenant doit contribuer continuer à
accueillir des migrants et d'autres
qu'ils iront pour que la france reste la
france
il faut limiter l'immigration parce que
ça te fait une diversité excessive et
donc c'est totalement faux la formule
n'est pas compris de la même façon par
tout le monde oui mais oui bien sûr
qu'il y en a dans les deux camps mais
enfin la grèce et la france où je ne
connais pas on a fait ce qui lui permet
en plus de dire vous voyez
au droit au retour prochain dans mon
slogan mais malgré tout dans l'opinion
l'écho de cette phrase c'est ya trop
d'immigration il ya trop il ya un islam
radical ou dangereux qui en train de
nous priver de notre identité au delà de
changer au delà des formes et on se
reconnaît plus dans le pays où on est et
ça c'est une angoisse qui lui aussi a
des problèmes trop d'immigration
el-assad est restée trop d'islam 1,1
point virgule un point une nouvelle là
j'ai pas compris dans le neuf est ce que
vous pouvez les fronts il ya pas de la
population que vous voulez vous que tout
le monde pense la même chose et je
pensais qu'il n'y a pas de lien du tout
entre l'immigration d'une part et
l'islam d'autre part et entre l'islam et
l'islamisme d'autre part et l'islamisme
l'islamisme radical d'autre part je
pense que vous et serait le personne ne
vous croira ici penser que les autres
l'immigration et l'islam entre l'islam
et l'islamisme autre liste à disputer
roj
donc l'immigration et bien voilà mais je
n'ai pas dit le donc non mais le
sentiment global de cette chaîne qui va
de l'immigration à l'islamisme radical
c'est dans tous les pays d'europe et
c'est alors les etats unis qui sont les
migrations se pose m'enfin c'est pas la
mer mais aussi tel que cette
dépossession des classes populaires
victime de la médiation des classes
moyennes qui se sont en train de se
paupériser et cette dépossession
culturelle cette angoisse culturel c'est
sa veuve y régnait ça c'est par tous
accusant sony lui alors il ad abord bien
avant c'est parfait mais enfin bon en
gros ce sentiment là on est d'accord
qu'il en soit m patrimoniale des
régniers compris patrimoine
imane merga car ils ont le sentiment de
le dire quelque chose
voilà qui met le doigt sur quelque chose
le sensible encore vous diverger sur les
réponses qu'il faut apporter mais on
peut pas dire que c'est absurde ou
purement démagogique dans le sujet non
c'est une angoisse si les gens si le
lien est pas forcément évident entre
d'un côté l'immigration et à l'autre
bout de la chaîne comme on vient de la
presse et vous n'êtes a tracé le
terrorisme que c'est certain c'est que
les gens ils le font d'une certaine
manière les problèmes sont là et pour
l'instant les réponses politiques à
l'échelle française européenne sont pas
vraiment apporté et qu'on efface plutôt
à une situation où on a plutôt tendance
à subir et que cette fameuse france dont
vous parliez tout à l'heure une france
généreuse quelques etc
elle est un peu battus en brèche parce
qu'elle s'est pas non plus traiter
correctement les problèmes comme des
russes et en même temps que ça qu'il
faut voir défendre
cette double face de la france qui est à
la fois généreuse et qui en même temps a
besoin de se défendre et de préserver
ses fondamentaux ses moyens c'est pas
pour continuer à rester ce qu'elle est
c'est vrai c'est un vrai sujet c'est un
sujet qui partagent vos votes à notre
question twitter parce que vous êtes 52%
à dire oui c'est un bon slogan
finalement oui c'est assez équilibré
alors tout dépend effectivement ce qu'on
met derrière ce slogan isométrique nous
dit c'est un très bon slogan identitaire
et percutant mais johan lui répond l air
qui devient identitaire quel dommage
et là isométrique toujours les français
sont tétanisés par le politiquement
correct
enfin faut pas charrier c'est votre
pseudo je trouve que c'est un slogan
creux qui a plein de sous-entendus
alexis ans quand même mot sur une
polémique assez semblables qui a frappé
gérard collomb la semaine dernière sur
d'une part à l'aller les migrants vont
du maïs marking et on assemble deux
régions qui sont submergés par l'afflux
de deux migrants
il se fait taper dessus et il se trouve
qu'avec au dos que ça et france info on
joue lorient on a testé ses trucs et 60%
des gens disent bah oui il a raison
donc ça prouve aussi que tous ces
thématiques l'ice à trouve une résonance
dans l'opinion mais là quand même
écoutez moi en général je suis pas
surpris par les résultats de vos
chaussettes pour ça vous et moi
d'habitude je
je vais en tenir exactement là quand
l'offre a lâché twitter s'est passé
ensuite les français poussé les
militants à l'air non c'est non c'est
non non mais si vous vouliez faire 100%
est ce que vous voulez que la france ne
restent pas la petite chance de les
avoir
on devrait vous consultez plus
souffrants olivier alors c'est là c'est
une vraie info en tout cas à l'heure où
je vous parle la loi sur les faits que
nous ça sera la manchette du figaro
demain n'est ce pas alexis on est on est
pas les grecs nous ont dit qu'ils me
levée de boucliers contre la loi sur les
technos puisqu'en fait la gauche et
contre l'extrême gauche est contre la
droite et contre l'extrême droite et
compte les saucisses son compte il ya
que en marche qui est pour le fil rouge
contre le monde est content
alors on va en parler c'est sow deux
textes relatifs à la lutte contre la
manipulation de l'information c'est
l'intitulé que le gouvernement entend
donc combattre en période électorale
alors donc avant même leur passage à
l'assemblée ses propositions de lois
déclenche les passions elles sont
liberticides pour marine le pen c'est
une police de la pensée nous a dit
christian jacob pour les républicains
voici comment benjamin griveaux porte
parole du gouvernement défend ses textes
on l'écouté je rappelle que les
candidats à l'élection présentielle où
les candidats aux élections châtiment on
parlera de sponsoriser des contenus sur
internet et donc on peut avoir des états
étrangers des groupes terroristes des
milliardaires excentré qui payent des
contenus les sponsorisent pour déverser
des tombereaux d'injures sur des
candidats quels qu'ils soient je
considère qu'il est normal qu'on puisse
avoir l'intervention d'un juge c'est en
période électorale
ce sont les quelques semaines qui
précèdent le vote san assassine en rien
la démocratie c'est au contraire à mon
avis aussi un meilleur moyen d'exercer
la démocratie alors ça m'assassine en
rien la démocratie nous dit benjamin
griveaux mais ça provoque une grille
bouclier je pense que c'est pas la
démocratie je pense qu'elle est inutile
inapplicable et qu'elle passe à côté du
vrai sujet
je pense que cette affaire prenons
quelques exemples
une noix un des reproches qui est une
des raisons de ces voitures contrôle
effectué au sein nombre de calomnies qui
ont été diffusées d'ailleurs pas
forcément par des puissances étrangères
parce que très souvent les effectifs
c'est pour des raisons commerciales qui
sont diffusées cd fabriquer ce qu'ils
sont en macédoine et c'est pour gagner
la plupart de l'argent pour faire bref
il y en a eu notamment contre macron
notamment il l'histoire du compte aux
bahamas etc
mais quand bien même on aurait ça en
période de campagne électorale le
imaginons que le candidat macro y voir
un juge des référés en disant on dit que
j'ai un compte aux bahamas judée fréhel
à 48 heures projet dont 48 heures il ne
peut évidemment pas savoir si un compte
aux bahamas ou non et qu'est ce qui dit
on rend je ne me prononce pas je renvoie
au fond et donc l'impression que ça
donnera c'est que le juge finalement les
laisse faire et va donc je pense est
impuissant non et si on prend l inverse
sur le plan des principes de cette
histoire de définition du feq news
l'allégation ou l'imputation d'un fait
dépourvue d'éléments vérifer de nature à
le rendre vraisemblable si on applique
ça à d'autres choses par exemple aux
révélations de mediapart c'est quand
cahuc ans quand mediapart le sort au
début il n'y a pas d'élément vérifiable
de nature à le rendre vraisemblable
qu'en d'autres journaux disent que
françois mitterrand la francisque qu'il
a une fille cachée et qu'il a une
maladie les malades eh bien il n'y a pas
d'élément vraisemblable ou vérifiables
on fait encore que pour l'heure francis
qui en avait mais enfin bon
donc moi cette histoire de dire la
vérité me paraît un peu gênante
il ya des choses qui sont bien qui
consiste notamment à dire que les
plateformes doivent divulguer les spawns
les les gens qui investissent de façon
publicitaires notamment les zetas a pour
sa part également des choses je pense
que le vrai problème c'est le poids
absolument faramineux que les
plateformes sont en train de prendre
dans no 6 dans nos démocraties et que
c'est pas du tout ceci ça qui permettra
de réduire texte inutile olivier duhamel
la loi effectivement 1880 il existait
déjà
les juristes le dilemmien complété il ya
déjà la loi de 1881 il ya le code
électoral pense que c'est une loi libère
stupide
voilà ce que je pense je suis assez
d'accord avec eux alexis je le disais
dans son jeu relier ça à votre sujet sur
les parlementaires je me disais c'est
dommage qu alexis soit pas parlementaire
et en commission sur ce sujet parce que
c'est exactement ça le travail que
devrait faire le parlementaire au lieu
de se demander quels amendements il va
proposer qu à leurs fins ils devraient
se dire quel est l'impact cette loi
qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce que va
produire comme n'est fait dans la
réalité la loi qu'on me demande de voter
est-ce qu'elle va permettre d'interdire
les choses qu'il faut interdire
et est-ce qu'elle va risque il interdire
des choses qu'il ne faut pas interdire
c'est ça au delà même du vous aviez
raison d'évoquer l'importance du travail
de contrôle
mais il ya aussi le travail d'évaluation
qui n'est pas fait de façon
satisfaisante et qui est beaucoup plus
important que le cirque
l'intervention publique ou de
l'amendement en soi et donc oui je vois
pas injuste qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quand on aimait des conjectures
scientifique
quand on émet des hypothèses sur la
dangerosité d'un médicament quand même
en dehors des sujets politiques
on pourrait allonger la liste comme ça
au début on n'a pas d'élément vérifiable
de la thur à le rendre vraisemblable
c'est le propre de l'anc est d'aller
chercher si bon et donc je suis la
définition vous semble déjà contestable
des films qui n'étaient pas dans l'eau
c'est d'ailleurs un amendement qu'ils
ont mais en cours de route semble
stupide celle rate sa cible alexandra la
faille c'est écoutez si on écoute
benjamin griveaux dans cette courte
intervention on a entendu
globalement on peut être que d'accord
lutter contre des états des puissances
étrangères qui veulent interférer chez
nous on est d'accord sur le principe
c'est une bonne idée en soi mais je vois
franchement concrètement pas comment ça
va être appliquée à passer comme quand
on veut parler du nuage de tchernobyl
pour dire il ne passera pas ou il
nécessairement il ya une espèce de avec
ce monde de l'information du numérique
il ya aujourd'hui des poèmes qu'ils
soient traités mais avec les bonnes
mesures et les bonne échelle
il ya peut-être effectivement des choses
à faire dans le domaine par exemple de
l'anonymat sur internet ou de l'anonymat
sur des outils comme twitter parce qu'à
un moment donné ça ça peut effectivement
poser question et ça permettra d'aller
plus vite si on veut aujourd'hui
effectivement là aussi régler une
certaine aux problématiques en utilisant
les arsenaux existants
parce qu'en fait on rajoute des lois
tout le temps qu on aime bien faire du
blanc pur sang que la loi va tout régler
effectivement on à la loi de 80 on a
toutes les lois qui permettent
effectivement de régler les
problématiques de diffamation par contre
il faut effectivement donner des moyens
aux juges pour aller beaucoup plus vite
peut-être modifier certains arsenault en
matière de sanction mais voilà on avait
sans doute assez de d'instruments et
d'outils pour toi être obligés de se
faire engueuler voyager mais là encore
je pense que parent je pense juste un
petit détail avec si je pense juste un
petit dédé je pense qu'on fait quelque
part c'est le pommeau du politique et à
un moment donné dit quelque chose et
après il est plus au pire je skie mes
skis emmanuel macron n'en fais pas une
affaire personnelle
mais oui mais c'est bien c'est bien le
problème c'est bien le problème parce
que on sait qu'il a très mal vécu
justement toutes les intox
pendant sa campagne présidentielle et
que c'est depuis ce moment-là que il
voit là il voulait s'en prendre aux
faits avec nous
mais le paradoxe si vous voulez c'est
que emmanuel macron préconise
le libérer le protéger et l'efficacité
surtout c'est quand même l'un de ses
maîtres mots c'est il dit il faut avoir
des résultats et nous on veut être
efficace et là on voit bien
donc là je j'abonde dans le sens de tout
ce qui s'est dit autour de cette table
que probablement ça ne sera pas efficace
donc c'est cdm il s'agissant de loi de
1881 moi qui me paraît une très bonne
loi sur la diffamation l'injure il ya
par ailleurs une autre loi qui punit
déjà la propagation de fausses nouvelles
c'est ça existe et il comporte est de
nature à aussi à ça existe tout ça oui
le truc c qui truquent projet
oui mais on ne peut pas les appliquer
aux plateformes car les plateformes dont
google facebook et tous et instagram et
c'est twitter n'ont pas le statut
d'éditeur de presse donc ils sont pas
sujets à ces lois là c'est le gars qui
est à l'autre bout du monde mais un
petit post sur google facebook
instagram twitter qui lui mais comme on
sait pas qui c'est qu'on n'a aucune
chance de retrouver ces morts est ce
qu'il faudrait pouvoir dire c'est
étendre l'application de ces lois de
dire finalement que les plateformes sont
responsables responsable pénalement et
civilement comme le sont les journaux ni
plus ni moins et là il n'est pas besoin
de dire le vrai le faux
c'est déjà ce qui est le cas aujourd'hui
aujourd hui des tribunaux dispac'h ce
qui est le vrai le faux
simplement quand le figaro publie
quelque chose dont quelques uns estiment
que c'est une diffamation ou d'injure ou
si jamais le gouvernement estimait que
c'était de nature à mettre en péril le
la sécurité publique ont entaché la
révolte d'un scrutin
le directeur de la publication du figaro
venir et devant être marc feuillée rey
devant le tribunal on va il n'y a qu'à
faire la même chose pour le directeur de
facebook ou le directeur france de
facebook si on veut pas toucher 1
america au de twitter et de et d'asta g
et tout ça c'est dans un registre
différent complémentaires comment vous
faites la part des choses entre l'afld
et news et la propagande quand par
exemple vous avez un chef de l'état qui
dit écoutez on a tenu une très grande
victoire sur les travailleurs détachés
quand on attend de l'état et c'est tout
est relatif quand vous avez un chef
quelqu'un qui dit contre la corée du
nord j'ai gagné moi je me maintiens ce
que j'ai dit dans ses choix parce que
quand même le texte fait est là c'est
pas un fait anodin sparco nous offrent
les pulls très libérale enfin toute
assez rigolo il dit et la résurrection
du christ résolution de jeter est ce que
c'est un fait d'autre peut on tout fait
malgré tout c'est un problème quand même
c'est marine qui l'a prouvé et ça ça
s'apprend tel accompagnement mais moi je
vais être là je vais être alors ça vous
fait réagir les uns les autres pour
notre question twitter vous dites à 78%
que oui ça peut mener à des dérives
liberticides
béatrice nous dit très inquiétant de
cette loi il faut déjà l'appliquer
appliquer celles qui existent la
démocratie est en danger quand un
gouvernement veut décider ensuite
humanisme décider ce que on a le droit
de dire ou pas anti mac sur lefigaro.fr
cette loi risque d'être appliquée
exclusivement au bénéfice du pouvoir en
place et amir le terme de fait que news
peut devenir un puissant outil pour
décrédibiliser les vérités le risque
c'est d'abus de pouvoir il n'est pas
chez le gouvernement c'est pas un
gouvernement qui laisserait aller chez
le juge
mais il ya une telle méfiance à l'égard
du gouvernement du pouvoir en soit en
france qu' on craint le pouvoir alors
que moi je pense que là il est chez les
plateformes parce que je pense que les
juges y
ils vont voir ce machin ils le mettront
de côté et parce qu'ils vont pas réussir
à 1,48 alors voulez-vous qu'on dit de
sauter sa revanche le risque à mon avis
ces cas semblent de plateformes
prenant les devants décide d'éliminer de
facebook de twitter tel ou tel qui ne
plaira pas ou au contraire pour embêter
les pouvoirs publics ce qu'ils ont fait
en allemagne
quand les allemands ont dit il faut que
les responsables de je crois que c'était
facebook soit reçoit eux-mêmes
pénalement responsable des appels à la
haine à la discrimination
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait pour rigoler
ils ont dit le ministre l'intérieur
allemand a dit ceci ça nous paraît un
appel à l'aide indiscrétions ce prime
son compte donc les plateformes peuvent
aussi s'appuyer là dessus pour faire
eux-mêmes elles mêmes leur propre
censure et la loi allemande elle l est
encore plus celle qui est passé est très
contesté les appels à la haine c'est pas
tellement sur la réalité ou la fausseté
d'une information csu avec des amendes
très très grave exemple très lourde mais
en même temps c'est vrai que c'est pas
normal encore qu'aujourd'hui le figaro
ou le monde où tous les médias où loeb
ce soit responsable du plus petit
commentaire il faut que qui arrive au
bout d'un artiste ou un gars nous
sillage pareil c'est un propos
antisémite raciste on en est pénalement
responsable c'est le vrai que facebook
peut passer des vidéos de décapitation
n'y a pas de responsable si ce n'est le
gars qu'il a postées qu'il ya en syrie
qu'on trouvera jamais c'est pas normal
j'ai qu'on aurait abordé les américains
passent quand même plus exactement des
plateformes des moteurs de recherche qui
sont tous américains et ça c'est
intéressant là là on a des vrais sujets
vous allez avoir du mal dans ma façon
avec la conception
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont alimenter alors
les américains ils diront pleine liberté
premier amendement est selon lui dira
commençons par le washington post
chacun alors je vous suggère à ce propos
de lire demain dans le figaro
l'interview de scat galloway scott
galloway c'est un grand spécialiste des
gaffes à eitb à l'usap occasion
justement c'est qu'il est temps de les
démanteler parce que pour toutes sortes
de raisons et notamment leur puissance
et leur hégémonie
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous
demain pour un nouveau point de vue
[Musique]